well i think something really uh big
that's different
is donald trump because in 2016 he was
running as an outsider
he said look i don't have 50 years of
political baggage i'm not paying back
favors i'm an outsider i'm a businessman
i know how to balance a budget i know
how to cut spending
and i know how to you know get get stuff
done basically and i'll bring the troops
home
and so that's why the polls got it wrong
because uh
people voted for him who had never voted
or who hadn't voted for 20 years
and so now uh it's four years later and
we can see that
he's acted pretty much like all the
professional politicians that he's
increased the deficit he's increased the
debt uh still hasn't brought the troops
home
so now i think that maybe people will
say you know
maybe republicans are beyond hope
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report as always guys don't forget to
subscribe
to our channel and click that pesky
notification bell
and joining me today is a senior
lecturer in psychology at clemson
university and
libertarian presidential candidate joe
jorgensen welcome to the reuben report
oh so glad to be here thanks for having
me well i'm thrilled to have you
and i know for sure that my audience is
thrilled to have you because i've
received roughly
four billion tweets saying why haven't
you had joe jorgensen on
so for the record uh we have been trying
to make this happen for a while
and we finally finally did make it
happen we weren't avoiding you and you
were not avoiding us
is that fair to say okay you just you
just couldn't catch up to the bus huh
back there
chasing my bus
[Laughter]
you've got a powered you've got a super
powered bus over there okay so
there's a lot of stuff that i want to
talk to you about and
i think you know a bit about my sort of
political evolution and probably most of
my
political stances you you may not know
that i actually did vote for the
libertarian candidate in the last
election i did vote for gary johnson i
had gary johnson
on my show i i like gary johnson um
i don't think he was you know the
strongest libertarian candidate
in a year that there was a moment for it
um so i guess my first question that'll
probably set up everything else
is if it didn't work in 2016 when
so many people were frustrated what is
different
this time what why should the
libertarians have hoped this time
well i think something really uh big
that's different
is donald trump because in 2016 he was
running as an outsider
he said look i don't have 50 years of
political baggage i'm not paying back
favors i'm an outsider i'm a businessman
i know how to balance a budget i know
how to cut spending
and i know how to you know get get stuff
done basically and i'll bring the troops
home
and so that's why the polls got it wrong
because uh
people voted for him who had never voted
or who hadn't voted for 20 years
and so now it's four years later and we
can see that he's acted pretty much like
all the professional politicians that
he's increased the deficit he's
increased the debt
uh still hasn't brought the troops home
so now i think that maybe people will
say
you know uh maybe republicans are beyond
hope now libertarians have known that
republicans are beyond hope since 1971
and that's why the party was formed
after
richard nixon stopped acting like a
republican but maybe now the republican
voters
and let me say there are many fine
republican voters who want smaller
government
it's republican politicians who aren't
giving it to them
and so maybe after having an outsider
come in
a businessman who supposedly compounds
the budget maybe
they'll say you know it's time for a
real outsider so what would you say
to the conservatives or the republicans
who want smaller government they want
lower taxes and they're looking and
they're going okay trump
did cut some taxes he got rid of some
regulation we're clearly not going into
other wars at the moment we're bringing
troops home
that are basically looking at that stuff
and going hey
trump did give us a bunch of the stuff
that that we want yes is the budget
going up yeah but the budget
or the deficit going up yeah but it
always seems to go up
do you think he's done anything right
from a libertarian perspective
well he has cut some regulations however
i'd like to point out
that a tax cut is also
going to be possibly an increase in
spending if they don't do anything to
make that up so
uh again he the the deficits are going
up either way yeah
yeah the exactly the bottom line is
spending's going up and that's what
counts
even if we're not paying for it this
year we'll be paying for it next year 10
years from now
20 years from now and that's that's what
matters
are you constantly amazed as a
libertarian that telling people
we want you to keep more of your money
is not more of a winning ticket i mean i
think when people
really hear it if you bash them over the
head with it over and over and over
again and you're like yeah
we want you to have your money not them
i think they do get it but it seems like
it's such an easy sale and yet for some
reason people just don't
understand it or don't absorb it
yes well what really frustrates me are
people like bill gates or oprah winfrey
who say yeah the government doesn't take
enough of my money
you know tax me more but look at what
bill gates does he starts the bill and
melinda gates foundation
uh does you know good work and uh oprah
winfrey opens up her own school
right over in africa well if they think
that the government
can do a better job than they can why
are they starting their own foundations
why not simply turn all of that money
over to the federal government
and so i think that actions speak louder
than words and if even they
aren't turning their money over i think
that that should send a message to
everybody else that hey
the government doesn't do a good job i
can't think of much that the government
does a better job
than the private sector and i think that
bill gates and
oprah winfrey and all these other
liberals who want bigger government i
think that they're just proving our
point for us
so what do you think is going on in
their heads there is it is it just
is it misguidedness or is it guilt
or is it that they know that the the
machine and the media will like them
more
if they take these positions i'm
hoping it's ignorance the true sense of
the word
ignorance because a lot of people just
don't understand how things work
and that's one of the biggest
compliments that i get from people
i just you know non-libertarian friends
after they meet me they say you know
what
i read the news differently now i look
at things differently now
they don't you know for instance yeah we
cut taxes okay what about spending
uh so you can look at things in a
superficial way and think things are
going great without
you know the understanding or the
underlying what's going on
uh beneath it all yeah does does the
thing that frustrates you
the most uh have anything to do with the
sort of
simplistic way we look at politics where
you know half of the country
seems to think that if you tell them
they're getting something for free they
seem to think it actually
is free and combating that notion
is almost impossible you say free health
care you say free education
you know free money now literally free
money it's like
that combating oh but you do have to pay
for it
that's just not what we do publicly very
well
yes i would have thought that with the
obama phone remember those
you know basically what obama's going to
reach into his back pocket and buy
everybody a phone
and that's what i've been telling
everybody about these 1200 checks that
they're getting
is that money is coming from somewhere
and
i i know that you know supposedly there
was a hold up because donald trump
wanted his name written on the actual
check well
i don't think that that check is coming
from his back pocket or his private
checking account it's coming from us
so somehow they give us money and and
and make it you know
make it seem like it's uh santa claus or
something but what's frustrating
is that that they take our taxes
out our income taxes so that we get a
tax
refund every year after april and so it
looks like we're getting something
and i wish they had never started that
practice i don't think we'd be where we
are now
if people actually had the had to feel
the pain
and right now people feel the pain when
they're teenagers and then they quickly
forget you know so many times i hear
about somebody's
uh you know friends uh kid who goes to
work
i'm like wait a minute i work 20 hours
this week
where's this money going and it's like
well welcome to the world of being an
adult welcome to the world of taxes
and so it feels painful then but by the
time you're 30 40 years old and
it's grown and grown you've kind of
forgotten about it so if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell